Hi, I'm James Kelly, a product
manager on the Android team.
And I'm here to talk
about Android Work.
Android Work is a
complete solution
to make Android awesome at work
for employees and businesses.
So let's start with apps.
Android Work has a
unified interaction model
across both personal
and enterprise apps,
which will make it
easier for employees
to have a single device
for personal use and work.
IT administrators will
be able to make apps
from Google Play available
to users and groups
within their organization.
We've enhanced the
Android framework
so that Android for
work devices offer
a unified view of
notifications and recents
in a single launcher across
both personal and work apps.
In the launcher, apps will be
badged with the Android work
logo to indicate to
the app and its data
are separately and securely
administered by IT.
Android Work has new features
to support organizations
that allow bring your
own device, or BYOD,
and companies that issue
corporate owned devices
to employees.
In BYOD, employees use their
Android device for work.
To enable this, an
IT administrator
can create a secure work
profile on the device
to separate apps and
data required for work
from personal apps and data.
We've made enhancements to
unify both personal and work
apps within the launcher and to
make notifications and recents
appear for either profile.
This creates a unified
user experience
but preserves
appropriate separation
to enable a secure
environment for business data.
For company owned
devices, IT administrators
can start with a new device.
And through a simple
provisioning step,
the enterprise is configured
to the devices owner.
A device owner is a special type
of device admin they cannot be
deactivated.
The company then has full
control of the entire device,
including data and apps.
The Android Work
device owner model
is designed specifically to
meet the highest requirements
for remote administration
and security
and builds on existing
Android concepts
of device administrator.
For this release,
we've added new APIs
to accompany the unified user
experience, support Android
Work profiles, and more.
A set of capabilities for
policy and app management
will be common across
all Android Work devices.
Let's start with
manage user APIs.
As part of activating
a device for BYOD,
a device policy client app
creates an Android Work profile
to separate company apps and
data from the personal space.
The Android Work profile is
created only after an employee
supplies a set of credentials
to their DPC approved by the IT
admin.
A work profile is
owned by the DPC
but is associated with the
primary user in such a way
that notifications and the
recents list are share.
Now moving on to
profile owner APIs.
A profile owner is a special
case of a device administrator
that has additional
capabilities.
As well as having access to
a number of additional API,
the profile owner cannot be
modified by the primary user.
Profile owners are scoped
to the Android Work profile,
and can only be defined as
part of the Android Work
provisioning process
approved by the IT admin.
Next, device owner.
A device owner is
like a profile owner,
but scoped to the whole device.
Device owner is an
additional level of privilege
and is a super set of
profile owner privileges.
Starting only from an
unprovisioned state,
a device owner can
affect the whole device,
including for
example Wi-Fi access.
All profile owner APIs are
accessible to device owners.
Android Work APIs
will primarily be
used by mobile device
management developers.
Other types of apps don't
need to designate themselves
as profile or device owner.
And that's an important point.
To most app developers, Android
Work will be transparent.
So going forward from
this Android release,
you can focus simply on
addressing enterprise needs.
Now, let's turn to Google Play.
Android Work introduces new
ways to support large scale app
deployment within an
enterprise via Play
for the Android Work profile.
An IT admin can select which
apps from the Play Store
are available for
their employees.
And this works whether a
company uses just a few apps
or hundreds.
Google Play will
offer enterprises
new options for licensing,
including bulk purchase.
So apps can be purchase and
deployed across organizations
in a single easy transaction.
As we touched on before,
enterprises normally
partner with specialist
mobility management companies
to manage their mixed fleets
of corporate owned and employee
owned devices.
And so new APIs on Google
Play allow enterprise mobility
management, or EMM providers,
to integrate Android device
management into their
existing products
or to offer value
added features.
Registered EMM providers can
offer secure authentication
to enterprise servers, control
access to enterprise apps,
and can set policies
to restrict what
the user can do within
the work profile.
On the device
itself, Google Play
will securely provision
apps within the Android work
profile.
The IT admin has
fine grained controls
to make apps from
Google Play available
to individual employees,
groups, or to the whole company.
IT admins can even deploy their
own internally hosted apps
direct to the work profile
via the Play Store app.
Finally, enterprise
applications sometimes
have some functionality
which is intended
to be configured by the IT
admin rather than the end user.
And so we've added
APIs for configuring
per applications policies.
EMMs can configure per app
policies using the device
policy client via a new
method in device policy
manager in the
Android framework.
I hope this was a useful
introduction to Android Work.
We are really excited to work
with our device partners, app
developers, and business to
help bring the power of Android
to the office.
For now, we have a
device admin code sample
and eight API documentation
available in the L Developer
Preview.
And later this year,
we'll have updates for you
as the first Android work
devices are announced.
It's been a real privilege
to introduce you to new ways
to securely work and play
on the devices you love.
And now it's over to
you, so that together,
we can make Android
Work for work.
My name is James Kelly
and thanks for watching.